but first I want to join some dots for
you tonight the Miller investigation the
media stormy Daniels last weekend's
White House Correspondents Dinner and
brexit it's all connected and here's how
let's start with the real world good
news on jobs good news on household
incomes good news diplomatically with
North Korea a lot of good news but the
sunday shows today on CNN and NBC they
were absolutely comically obsessed with
who said what when over stormy Daniels
the Miller probe and all the rest of it
the elitist media don't care about real
issues in real policy because it doesn't
affect them they don't care about jobs
and incomes because they're rich and
comfortable they don't care about
education because their kids go to
private schools or they live in such
fancy neighborhoods that the public
schools are practically private schools
anyway they don't care about the real
world they've never created a job or
done anything useful their whole world
is just words the way they cover this
president they're not political
reporters anymore they're just TV
critics what did Trump say what do you
think about Rudy Giuliani's latest
performance now here's where it comes
together with the White House
Correspondents Dinner last weekend peggy
noonan in the wall street journal wrote
something so powerful about Jake Tapper
and Morning Joe nor the Trump hating
crew here she is the dinner is elite
journalists telling half of America we
hate you it's as if they break out of
there this just in face and say you know
how you think we don't share your values
and respect your views you know how you
think that we are biased self infatuated
twerps who think we're better than you
it's true
we do ha ha ha as we saw today on the
sunday shows the elitist media usually
tried to cover up their hatred of Trump
and his supporters in high-minded
pontificating about democratic norms and
the rule of law but that facade was
blown apart this week first by George
Ellis on Friday when he showed that the
real threat to democracy in the rule of
law is the Miller investigation itself
as the judge put it you don't really
care about mr. manna for you really care
about what information mr. manna fault
can give you to lead you to mr. Trump
and and
impeachment the American people feel
pretty strongly about no one having
unfettered power exactly the ruling
elite want unfettered power to get rid
of the man they hate they want to
overturn the 2016 election and now let's
bring stormy Daniels into the picture
whatever happened in the past the agenda
now is very clear just listen to her
lawyer I do not think that the president
will last through the balance of his
term I just don't now we're gonna find
out if I'm right or wrong
but I think he's gonna ultimately resign
the presidency mr. Trump will not serve
out his term no way no how he will be
forced to ultimately resign I believe
that ultimately he will be forced to
resign due to information that his is
going to come to light in connection
with our case as well as the raids by
the FBI that's what it's about
finally let's connect stormy Daniels and
brexit now that's something I bet you
never thought you'd hear in one sentence
over in the UK right now the ruling
elite is plotting to overturn the
Popular's Revolution that led to the
brexit vote the debate is whether to
kind of stay in the EU really or to have
a second referendum you know because the
people got it wrong the first time
breaks it stormy Daniels the Miller
investigation the White House
Correspondents Dinner the elitist media
it is all one extremely ugly picture the
ruling elite saying to you the people
how dare you try and take power away
from us we're not going to stand for
that we are witnessing a
counter-revolution by elitists
everywhere and for the sake of democracy
and the rule of law it must be
confronted and defeated I'd love to know
what you think of that please follow us
at Steve Hilton X and that next Rev fnc